hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remembered so you don't have to let's
talk about Burt Reynolds in the 70s and
80s he was one of the biggest stars in
the world with big hits like Longest
Yard deliverance and Smokey and the
Bandit Burt was on top of the world but
his attitude started making headlines he
would go through a messy divorce get in
fights on shows even slap reporters on
air on top of that he filed for
bankruptcy because of bad investments
and an extreme lifestyle after a while
people stopped hiring him because they
were fucking scared shitless of it
sounds like a perfect guy to put next to
a little kid
yes this was considered the low point in
Burt Reynolds career a little kid wants
to be a cop so officer fuck the world is
on the case to babysit in the movie so
desperate they couldn't even afford a
Culkin it's embarrassing it's not funny
you want to see me suffer through it
like the sick pigs that you are let's
not waste any time this is cop and a
half so as we hear the music to the
opening credits we can see that this is
gonna be some campy stupid shit
listen to the back anything more corny
than this it's like the opening to a
1950 film stream in fact I won't be
surprised if the Fonz himself directed
that I'm an that shot credits and cracks
bar we open with our main character
named Devin he's a little boy who's
totally obsessed with being a police
officer to a point where he plays it all
the time with his friend
freeze dirtbag yeah here I'm history uh
when did they combine high school and
kindergarten class in the same building
Oh think she's a real job yeah that
calls for payback dude Sam from Clarissa
explains it all a bit of a dick isn't he
at least now we know where he got the
money to pay for that ladder I'm into
demonizes way too bad so it gets his
head dunked in a toilet and somehow gets
in trouble for it plus he sent to the
principal's office do I sense a little
insolence lies are not explanations I'm
not lying
everyday these big Jumbo's come and take
my money they put me in the toilet and
hold me upside down
as you can see devon has been taking
acting lessons but even the great Jake
Lloyd would be jealous uh I have to call
your grandmother but on his way home
Devon comes across a chase scene with
one of the city's most badass cops
get your filthy butt off my car Wow he
does a really good nor McDonald
impression doesn't he that's what's up
the hotel looks like drugs it does looks
more like my old mad scientist chemistry
set holy shit doctor we were making
drugs why do you think I don't manic all
the time
hey my you know I am um don't you think
you should cop in by now I mean it just
gives some ample opportunity to do bad
bad or bad yeah now you get the idea hey
next time why don't you read him his
rights after he's executed I'm gonna tie
it ah cuz I don't want you getting in my
car okay you ready I don't think this is
part of the script I think this is Burt
Reynolds just being Burt Reynolds so
Devon who of course has no parents and
lives with his grandma has plenty of
free time to notice one of the cars
Reynolds was chasing it calls the police
oh wait I forgot that he is the police
so he goes to solve it himself look kid
you're not penny gadget she had a
computer book an IQ of gazillion you had
a bit part in sisters I don't think
that's gonna get you very far
so he follows the bandits under the
cover of dark blue filter day for night
when suddenly he comes across their
crime boss and I use that term very
loosely well I'm the type of guy that
likes to roam around oh they call me the
wonder of don't wander oh here here to
wander all around and round and round
and round it boss you killed me yeah you
are my idol mr. fountain okay which
reaction should I go with here um that
one's pretty good it's not bad either no
I think for this one I'm gonna go with
number two see what the truckload of
Christ look yeah this is the crime boss
they follow the head of this divisions
mafia I guess I shouldn't be too
surprised if this henry winkler
directing it so i guess it figures they
jump the shark pretty fuckin early in
the game woo Joo is the fishing here get
rid of it you gotta boss what are you
doing I never said a word to McKenna
blitz blacks I won't take it about Jesus
these Schmucks are making the
goodfeathers look legitimate all about a
Saturday night get him out of my face
Devon does see a Hegeman get murdered
and writes down the license plate
information this means he's considered a
witness by the police department but
there's just one little catch with that
you need me to testify and identify
right yes I'd like to clinic deal he
wants to be a cop that's right he won't
give the information unless they make
him an official cop oh why don't you
just go ahead and give us that plate
number make me a cup why do you want to
be a cop look at this guy raggedy ANNs
clothes bad back bad marriage
attitude she talking about the character
of Burt Reynolds they're just shit me
know before her coming here where don't
know where I got a name what's the name
I really want to give his name you put
me on duty yours
now in any other reality I think we all
know exactly how this would go down I
want to be a cop or you don't get any of
the information you need okay so why
don't you come with me give me the name
what a search out for Shire Baggins but
in this realm of retardation we find
that the police will make him a cop for
a while just so they can get the
information and on top of that let's put
the obvious last person they should on
this assignment literally just for shits
and giggles
you owe me I don't know you number I
don't owe you we got that hey if
clemmy's what can act with an orangutan
you can act with a little boy so then
the mob boss finds out about the witness
and decides to act right after he's done
recording his album you're amazing
really think so yeah why is it I get the
feeling he gets picked on at the annual
monster meetings they called me the
wanderer don't wander out here to wander
so Reynolds and Devon are now a team I'm
gonna predict that this is high jinks
angular my shield my badge all right
yeah yard always wanted one of these get
in a car darling I doing here
you give me no joy hey I think that was
the critical recommendation for the DVD
so they banter a bit he acts annoying he
acts stupid he thinks a purse is being
stolen when really it's just a guy
returning it to his wife it's pretty
fucking boring
there's even a fruit stand they don't
knock over how can you call yourself a
1990s buddy cop movie and not knock over
the goddamn fruit stand but one cliche
you're supposed to follow and you fucked
it up look at Reynolds he's supposed to
be acting in the scene but you know all
these thinking in his head is god I want
to eat that for stink I don't wanna hit
that first day bam-bam-bam we're just
flying everywhere but no you totally
missed it hand over your badge movie
you're suspended give me the plate play
number and sings b7 to G okay so the kid
finally gives them the license-plate
number as well as the name II heard
called Bobo it turns out the license
plate is under a fake name so all they
have to go on is finding out who Bobo is
so logically the kid is of no use now
they can just drop him back home right
fuck that shit we still got an hour left
he's staying around whether it makes any
sense or not I'm listening to you you're
letting the kid answer the phone police
station officer brother hear what the
cat look like calm down no I mean hello
yeah no shit I'm hanging up too
what if there was a real emergency going
on on the other line hello officer
Buckner speaking it's a so I was trying
to break into your home you say the
robber hits go what does my husband will
see you for negligence me guys
so they go looking for all the Bobo's in
town the first one is a crazy artist
who's in his own little world detective
Butler is your name Bobo perfect listen
I don't think this is the guy again I
would much rather know the story of this
guy rather than anyone else in the movie
but let's keep following our heroes we
see they find another Bobo who's getting
thrown out of his apartment by his wife
because he forgot their anniversary
today feels like a Wednesday I don't
know pammi like hey come on I'm a Danny
DeVito decoy here don't make me do any
more my New York Italian stereotype oh
but death and heads up there and set
everything straight with his
unbelievable words of wisdom you think
it's bad you forgot an anniversary it's
not so bad I have these big Jumbo's who
always throws me in a toilet you to at
least have each other
yeah you may be right
oh great devin la vita swore with your
enlightenment hey I'm from outer space
so Devon is dropped off at his home but
finds them mob bosses there posing as a
school counselor to see if he recognizes
him you recognize me no you haven't seen
me around school huh no deffend doesn't
let on at first but he eventually
figures out that it's in he does the
smart thing and calls the cops to let
him know that he came by so what now put
him and his grandma in the witness
protection program
well how about giving Devon a sleepover
with Burt Reynolds and keeping grandma
in the exact same fucking location no
wonder they even solved this case yet
these cops are as logical as the justice
system in Wonderland Nickleby Oh take
care yourself dead I will on November
14th Devon Butler was asked to remove
himself from his place of residence that
request came from the half-assed Police
Department with nowhere else to go he
appeared at the home of dick cheese
actor Burt Reynolds several years
earlier Burt's wife threw him out
requesting that he never returned Ken to
obnoxious personality share an apartment
without driving each other crazy
well no badge no law after more
bickering is shit-ass dialogue we see
Reynolds here's a sound in the middle of
the night
shut up shut up John shut up
oh god we got ended the movie right
there bro so Reynolds decides he can't
do this because well he's a fucking
psycho with a gun but the chief sees it
different oh I guess the kid has gotten
to you huh get the kid to MacPhail likes
corn flakes ah he bonded with him cuz he
almost shot him
so another officer gets to look after
the kid one who will most assuredly
treat him with much more responsibility
than Reynolds did book him Danno
license and registration please mr.
Flemmi goodbye your car please sir oh
yeah this won't draw any attention to
the kid at all nobody would ever find a
little boy pulling over a grown man for
speeding suspicious my god Dudley
fucking do-right would follow better
protocol on these idiots
I trust my life to a donut before I put
it in the hands of these fucking yokels
and I know what you're thinking Oh what
are the chances of some of the henchmen
stumbling across and while he's doing
this well guess what some of the
henchmen stumble across him while he's
doing this your tax dollars at their
fuck is people wait what did he say duh
can somebody please help debbye be sure
to let that Bao know the he said damn it
big chopper
oh no they were gonna miss anyway
so it's decided that he should look
after the boy its Reynolds decides to do
the safe thing again by bringing him on
his assignments if you haven't guessed
yet folks I'm not blown away with the
police work here you mr. bubble
ask your mother okay cuz I want to talk
to you he gets in a fight with the real
Bobo guy when suddenly the kid has an
idea to bail him out really the people
honestly thought the little kid at the
microphone was a cop that's pretty dumb
Kimmy what's next a hostage negotiation
handled by a three year old girl though
I don't have a bit I'm just askin so the
next day Reynolds decides again that
he's not qualified to look after the kid
no ping-pong balls that don't go back
and forth as much as he does are you
some kind of bonehead or what I can't
handle this anymore I cannot handle it
anymore you caused this being a father
which Peter we are not your father
no I am your father I'm not your partner
either fine I don't want you to be my
father I don't want you to be my partner
I'm gonna handle things myself ah Devin
dad
debbye oh my god he has a hard enough
time saying the kid's name the Stallone
does saying the word law you betray the
law ah you kept
so yeah goes to the school playground
where more hitmen try to get it you know
because a public place like that
certainly won't draw any attention to an
assassination
all right everybody sit out where is
Kevin Butler I'm Devon Butler I'm Devon
Butler I'm Spartacus I'm Spartacus I'm
Spartacus I'm Devon Butler oh hi
fire did this movie just invent the
Twinkie cam that needs to be seen more
but just when it looks like debe escaped
it appears the kid is actually stupid
enough to sneak inside their car and get
caught you have the right to remain
silent anything you say no no again that
would make sense but instead they just
bring the kid to the crime boss who then
tells them that they can shoot him don't
you think you were told him to do that
in the first place hey Bobo you're late
it's Burt Reynolds it's Burt Reynolds
it's Burt Reynolds he's half the size
he doesn't talk it's Burt Reynolds
i-it's Burt Reynolds so he punches the
thugs and writes the kid out on the bike
or he walks right past the bike n and
traps himself deeper inside the
warehouse
I thought someone almost grew a brain
cell there stay put but then Reynolds
suddenly realizes do I have a boy and
uses that to escape right before
stealing one of the gangsters boats
I'm gonna jump the pipe
so the gangsters decide they can do the
exact same thing do the exact same thing
ended up in a completely different
location that's a lot of fish so the
cops arrest the mob boss and we end with
Reynolds and taking a boat ride with his
grandma this is
you
that was weak and this movie is stupid
what else can you say but kill me
the little boy isn't very entertaining
Burt Reynolds always looks like he's
ready for lunch and the plot is every
boring throwaway cliche from both kids
films and cops films from the 1990s it's
a pile of ass on a pile of balls with a
pile of dick what's that make a pile
load of ass ball dick well mr. director
what do you have the save yourself
hey hey fuck you I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember so you don't
god I wanted that first and got on
oh god I wanna hit that first day